JuJustin Massie, Charles-Philipe
DaDavid.
BoBonsoir à vouous deux.
IlIl y a eu beaucoup de mouvemes
auau chapitre de la guerre en
UkUkraine cette semaine. Moscoua
coconfirmé avoir frappé Kiev hir
plpleine visite secrétaire génél
dede l'ONU. Des frappes qui ont
étété condamnées aujourd'hui de
totoutes parts. Quel est le
memessage à votre avis que la
RuRussie a voulu envoyer?
- - Je pense qu'on va tous être
d'd'accord pour dire que ce
memessage a été envoyé ce que
VlVladimir Poutine ne pense pas
grgrand-chose de la communauté
ininternationale et des règles i
onont prévévalu dans les derniès
dédécennies. L'ONU n'a pas
vrvraiment un jeu de rôle
imimportant à jouer. Cet affront
popour moi, s'ajoute à la longue
liliste de cette attitude ou dee
cocomportement tout à fait
didictatorial de la part de
popoutine. Il est seul maître àà
bobord selon lui. La diplomatie
n'n'a pas sa place sauf si
ZeZelenski adhère aux conditions
etet l'Occident aussi. Ça ne se
fefera pas. Dans ce contexte-là,
ilil a dit: il n'y a plus de ple
etet de temps pour la diplomati.
OnOn attend le résultat de cette
guguerre et il attend certainemt
dede voir que ses troupes
l'l'emportent au moins dans le
rereste dans le sud de l'Ukrainà
dédéfaut d'avoir gagné Kiev et
d'd'avoir gagné le nord de
l'l'Ukraine, qu'il puisse au mos
obobtenir cela de son point de
vuvue. La perspective de
nénégociation n'est pas sa
prpriorité selon moi.
- - Donc aucun résultat à avoir?
MMême pas pour l'évacuation des
cicivils en quoi ça Marioupol?
- - Si vous me posez la questio,
popour les couloirs humanitaires
didire que c'est laborieux est n
eueuphémisme. Je ne sais pas
cocombien de professionnels rens
d'd'essayer de trouver une façon
papar lesquels les civils peuvet
êêtre évacués en toute sécurité
sasans devoir subir de tirs
d'd'artillerie, d'obus ou de
bobombardement. Ça se produit, e
vovous le dis, laborieusement.
MaMarioupol je pense qu'on en et
àà une demi-douzaine de promesss
ququi ont été faites depuis une
sesemaine. Pas une fois on a eua
sisituation s'améliorer pour les
vivilles. Il y a toujours je ne
sasais pas exactement où on
ananimait 100 000 civils sont
prprisonniers Marioupol. Toujous
leles militaires ukrainiens qui
sosont là. Continue malgré les
prpromesses de poutine de
sususpendre les bombardements. l
y y a eu encore apparemment
bobombardement hier. La situati,
esest terrible pour les civils.
InInacceptable.
- - Justin Massie, on avait les
yeyeux en direction du Donbass,e
PePentagone qui a déclaré que la
reretard en raison de toute cete
rérésistance ukrainienne dans le
DoDonbass, dans son offensive
cocontre le Donbass. Est-ce que
vovous voyez cette lamentation?
- - C'est exact. C'est en grande
papartie grâce aux armes que
l'l'OTAN fournisse que les État-
UnUnis et le Canada et l'Europe
ququi permet de résister à cette
ofoffensive. Et à limiter les
gagains. Il y en a eu des gains
rurusses mais ils sont au minim.
EtEt il coûte énormément cher à
l'l'armée russe en termes de
pepersonnel et d'équipements qui
sosont détruits. On peut penser
quque ça prendra plusieurs
sesemaines encore que cet
afaffrontement là-bas se poursu.
- - On a parlé de ça lors de ces
bobombardements acquiert pendant
lala visite secrétaire généralee
l'l'ONU. Premier bombardement
dedepuis la mi-avril dans la
cacapitale. Est-ce que vous y
vovoyez une stratégie militaire?
OuOu une provocation.
- - Je pense que le message quia
êêtre envoyé ce que la Russie
pepeut frapper partout en Ukrai.
ElElle veut dissuader les forces
dede l'OTAN de donner ce mataté.
OnOn veut diviser les opinions
pupubliques, on veut menacer
d'd'armes nucléaires. Pour limir
cecet approvisionnement qui est
crcrucial à la résistance
ukukrainienne. Le message qu'on
didisséquait peut-être les forcs
teterrestres russes ne sont pas
papartout sur le territoire mais
leles missiles russes peuvent
frfrapper l'ouest, loin nord le
susud, partout.
- - On parle beaucoup d'armemens
fofournis. Les États-Unis ont
alallongé, il pense ajouter 30 3
mimilliards de dollars. C'est ce
ququi a été annoncé par Joe Bidn
popour aider l'Ukraine.
- - J'ai presque le goût de dire
quque la semaine se termine
coconsacré presque le changement
dadans cette guerre d'une guerre
RuRussie et régionale avec
l'l'Ukraine en confrontation
frfranchement indirecte avec les
EÉtats-Unis et la Russie.
EÉvidemment avec les ennemis de
l'l'Ukraine en Europe avec le
CaCanada notamment. Je pense que
JoJoe Biden a augmenté
sésérieusement l'implication des
EÉtats-Unis dans cette guerre.
PaPar son annonce qui multiplie
papar huit les engagements déjà
ququ'il avait pris et que le
cocongrès des États-Unis avait
prpris pour soutenir l'Ukraine.3
mimilliards, c'est énorme comme
aiaide. Évidemment il y a de
l'l'aide économique, humanitaire
mamais il faut savoir que le
trtrocart de cet art c'est une
aiaide militaire directe. Pour
vevenir en aide à l'armée
ukukrainienne pour pouvoir
rérésister à l'offensive russe.e
soson côté, poutine, la seule
ststratégie fonctionne cette
ststratégie presque de terre
brbrûlée. Comme il a déjà pratié
enen Tchétchénie en série. C'es-
àà-dire de détruire les
ininfrastructures ukrainiennes,e
chchasser les civils. Son
ofoffensive sur le plan militai,
MaMadeleine. Elle apparaisse das
lele n'en autour de la capitale.
ElElle a fait des progrès dans e
susud dans de l'Ukraine, mais si
ceces approvisionnements
ococcidentaux et surtout
amaméricains arrivent à aider
l'l'armée il est possible qu'on
asassiste à une impasse des
avavancées et des reculs de la
papart de la Russie dans le sud
dadans les qu'une victoire
frfranche, une victoire décisive
dede l'armée russe pour acquérir
totous les sites de l'Ukraine et
auau fond procéder à une force e
papartition. Part avec le Donbas
etet laisse le reste à Zelenski
paparce qu'il ne peut plus gagnr
totoute l'Ukraine. Ça risque de
dudurer un bon moment le
sesecrétaire général de l'OTAN à
paparler de moi et même d'année.
OnOn va voir mais il est clair e
l'l'implication américaine danse
sosociale armée ukrainienne, on
paparle d'imaginer que ces armes
pupuissent se rendre en trois
jojours. C'est quand même très u
dede temps.
- - On ne sait pas comment
VlVladimir Poutine va réagir à
totoute cette qui a été annoncé.
EsEst-ce qu'on s'approche de pls
enen plus d'une guerre par
prprocuration?
- - Oui absolument. Clairement e
didirige vers une impasse par
prprocuration. Les Russes ne
pepeuvent pas se permettre des
ininsuccès. Vladimir Poutine
vrvraiment qualifier cette guere
exexistentielle pour la sécurité
nanationale russe. Ne peut pas e
pepermettre la défaite. Ce qui i
rereste motivé l'escalade. Il ya
dedeux types d'escalade:
nunucléaires mais il y a d'autrs
opoptions qui sont sur la table.
L'L'une qui va prendre considérr
c'c'est la mobilisation générale
dede la population pour augmentr
leles forces militaires russes
popour poursuivre.
- - Vous pensez qu'on va mobilir
leles Russes eux-mêmes et les
enentraîner dans cette guerre l?
- Les Russes ont perdu des
didizaines de milliers de solda.
L'L'une des options c'est
d'd'augmenter ses contingents l.
AuAugmenter la construction qui
esest faite en Russie pour aller
coconstruire la totalité ou une
grgrande partie de la population
popour augmenter les forces
mimilitaires russes. Pour avoir
plplus de main-d'oeuvre et être
cacapable de poursuivre cette
pepensée.
- - Mais bien sûr il y a un danr
avavec ça. Le risque c'est de
rerevivre l'expérience de
l'l'Afghanistan qui a duré prese
1010 ans. Beaucoup de conscrits
fufurent mis à contribution pour
sosoutenir l'armée russe et si a
RuRussie ne gagne pas, je veux
bibien croire que la stratégie e
memensonge de poutine puisse
fofonctionner hélas un bout de
tetemps, de tiers aux trois quas
dede sa population achète le
memessage de ce qu'il fait en
UkUkraine justifiée, mais moment
dodonné il aura des comptes à
rerendre. Je ne peux pas croire
quque ça ne se sera pas que
bebeaucoup de soldats russes
memeurent au combat. On ne peut
papas évidemment affirmer que ls
chchiffres sont avérés. Mais si
leles chiffres minimalement de 5
00000 voire jusqu'à 25 000
ZeZelenski a-t-il affirmé soldas
rurusses ont péri en Ukraine, ce
sosont des chiffres astronomiqu.
JeJe pense que plus la guerre va
dudurer longtemps, il y a aussie
ririsque pour poutine qu'il ne
pupuisse pas affirmer le 9 mai
lolors de sa grande parole pour
cécélébrer la seconde guerre
momondiale, la victorieuse,
sosoviétique à l'époque. Il ne
popourra pas affirmer qu'il a
gagagné son plan de bataille ou
soson combat en Ukraine. Il y an
ririsque à terme pour lui mais
dadans l'immédiat ça n'aide pasa
cacause de Sauvé, et parmi des
cicivils de ces dommages. Comme
l'l'a dit Justin, l'escalade est
popossible. Ce qu'on a vu en
TrTransnistrie le week-end dernr
popourrait bien se reproduire et
ququi sait si poutine ne pourrat
papas être attirée par un
élélargissement du conflit. Quoi
quque ça lui coûte très cher, ds
unun pays comme la Moldavie et
memettre l'OTAN dans une situatn
dédélicate.
- - C'est assez imprévisible.
JaJamasi croyez-vous qu'il y a s
ririsques réels de débordement n
MoMoldavie?
- - Il faut comprendre que la
ququantité de troupes russes en
TrTransnistrie c'est pas une foe
ququi est suffisante. On parle e
101000 soldats environ. Pour les
rerecettes difficiles
d'd'approvisionner cette régionà
cacar il doive voler au-dessus e
l'l'Ukraine. Contenu des insuccs
dadans l'est du pays je pense qe
leles Russes auraient tout intét
àà concentrer leur attention das
cecette région donc basse plutôt
ququ'ouvrir un autre front qu'is
auauraient de la difficulté à
memener.
- - On parlait du prochain sommt
dudu G20 favori en novembre. Les
dedeux présidents ont été invit,
cece qui n'avait pas l'affaire s
EÉtats-Unis. Joe Biden a déclaré
ququ'il ne ferait pas semblant e
ririen. En terminant vous vous
atattendez à quoi concernant G2?
- - Je m'attends à une
coconfrontation. Des fortes
rereprésentations américaines
ébébranlement des déclarations
inintempestives de la part du
prprésident des États-Unis. Sure
plplan diplomatique lueur d'espr
sosont très dénudé